When people ask you what happened here,
tell them King James still rules the East.
Also, tell them I'm better than Michael Jordan.
He said what?
Your generation is soft with your
load management and your analytics
and your AAU Superhouses.
The Gods of the game will not stand for this.
A reckoning is coming.
Hello old friend!
Ah, Ser Dwyane. Welcome to the Mediadel.
Thank you.
I’m so delighted to be teammates again.
Likewise. We need you.
We’re a man down without Chuck.
Wait, what? Where is Ser Charles?
He’s like the funniest guy on the sh-
...I mean...well,
Well, luckily I’m ready to go.
I’ve actually prepared a bit.
It’s called ‘Wade’s Grades.’ You see, it—
Woah woah, slow down, chief.
You can’t be on the show until you’ve earned your press pass.
Press pass? How do I get a press pass?
You audition.
An audition? I’m Dwyane Wade!
Don’t worry, they make it easy on ex-knights.
You just do a quick apprenticeship
and then present your findings to the other maesters.
You’ll be reporting on an injury.
Apprentice to Maester Marc Stein
in his investigation of an injury
to a horse?
Oh, I get it. You’re being funny.
Four full MCL tears.
Four full ACL tears.
Four full Achilles tears.
And a full neck tear.
Looks like the horse will be out…
indefinitely.
So what happened?
Foul play?
My working theory is that
Robin Lopez mistook him for a mascot.
I’ve seen that mark before.
My squire season I think.
Yes, it’s hand-checking, no?
Hand-checking?
Don’t be silly, Dwyane. That was banned years ago.
What was this horse doing when it got hurt?
Horse things I assume.
Take this report to the ravenry.
Make haste. I don’t want to get scooped.
Um… ravenry… ravenry…
Oh! Um, excuse me, Maester Wind Horse.
Ah, Ser Dwyane.
I’m supposed to take this to the ravenry.
Do you know where that is?
I do. I’m going there now.
Come.
Poor thing.
Tell me about it.
A future Hall of Famer
serving as an errand boy to Marc Stein...
I meant the horse. Out indefinitely.
Seems he paid a heavy price for speaking ill of His Airness.
Where did you hear that?
My little birds are everywhere—
well...mostly around LeBron,
but some other places, too—
Have your little birds told you anything else about this horse?
I noticed a strange mark.
No. Since the horse injury,
my birds from Tor’Onto have become useless.
They’re just repeating the same things over and over.
What kind of things?
Oh, how knights these days are soft,
how the '90s were the best,
how Ser Jordan is the GOAT.
Boring old man stuff, really.
Boring, eh?
Could it be related to the Soul Box?
Hm, I didn’t think to make that connection.
But then again, I don’t have your instincts.
I never played the game.
You never played?
No. Everything I learned about basketball, I learned…
in here.
Whoa.
So many books.
All the stories, records, recaps, box scores
and even memes.
They all live here.
We are this world’s memory, Dwyane.
Without us, the histories and legends of our Realm
would all vanish
like James Harden in a meaningful playoff game.
Some say if it’s not in here...it never happened.
Now if you’ll excuse me for one moment, Dwyane,
I need to grab a book.
Wait, I can’t come in?
I’m afraid this is very sensitive information.
Only Maesters with a press pass can enter.
Hello Dwyane.
Ser Paul.
There is no more Paul. There is only...
The Truth.
Right.
Now that I am in the media, I see all.
I know all...and yes,
I am better than you.
Um...
I have to go now.
Is he…?
All right, let’s go.
Well this looks like a nice place to have
a long-form, intimate conversation about basketball.
Ah yes, here is where we do our pondcasts.
Here we are.
Whoa.
Welcome to the ravenry.
This is where the Mediadel and fanlings connect,
or some say, even merge.
The network of platforms you see represents
the various localities that make up the greater ‘Social Mediadel,’
a never-ending conversation between fanlings,
scribes and knights.
You see, until very recently,
only those cloaked in Mediadel chains
could reach all corners of Balleros.
But no longer.
So, what do you have for me?
I have this injury report
I’d like to send out from Maester Stein. How do I—
Horse out indefinitely?
I broke that 10 minutes ago. Haha!
Wind Horse, what about you?
Another story about LeBron?
Those were different times.
THIS is a story about how Luka Doncic…
...is the next LeBron.
-This generation is soft!
-No fundamentals!
-Jordan is the GOAT!
Wind Horse, look!
Looks like it’s not just my ravens.
What in the Seven Hells is going on in Tor’Onto?
-Jordan is the GOAT!
-This generation is soft!
Well whatever it is, it seems to have spread.
Dwyane, we’ve got to get to Cream City!
I agree—oh wait.
My audition. It’s tomorrow night.
Don't worry. I'll get us there in no time.
For I am as fast...
as the wind.
You little mumblecrust,
I’ll rip your bloody antlers off!!
Robin, come on, bruv.
It’s supposed to be play wrestling, ya know?
This bastard tricked me
into signing a giant fake contract!
What the...
I ask that you bestow on me the gift of range.
Please, Jesus...
Shuttlesworth.
Giannis!
Come quick. We’re being attacked.
Is this some sort of scheduling mistake?
I didn’t think there was a battle today.
Wind Horse, look!
There's Giannis.
This generation is soft.
Jordan is the GOAT.
LeBron is weak.
Dwyane. Get down.